Star Trek vs Star Wars Batman vs
Superman
scp-096 versus
scp-682 we just can't seem to resist
putting icons against each other what
can we say it's fun to see how two
powerful forces would go up against one
another and which one would come out on
top fortunately at the SCP Foundation we
can justify pretty much anything by
saying it's for research purposes trying
to make infinite money using scp-914
well that's just research giving a can
of soda to scp-999 to watch it bounce
off the walls research making infinite
margaritas with scp-294 while you're
still on the clock it's totally fine
Ethics Committee it's just research now
putting two SCP Foundation mobile task
forces together and making them fight
isn't playing God and risking lives for
your own Petty Amusement it is sit with
me now research more specifically it's
cross-testing sure that term generally
applies only to scps but people who ask
too many questions don't survive long at
the foundation instead let's talk about
the answers to a question we pose to all
of you what if cross-tests were done on
mobile task forces which specialized
groups would you test with one another
what kind of chaos do you think would
ensue we asked our community here at SCP
explain for your ideas and you all
really let your creativity shine so
without further Ado let's see what
happens when we pit spy against spy
brain against Braun or the cold
calculated expertise of the red right
hand against the unpredictable nonsense
of Dr bright Sharkey Reynolds said I
can't imagine MTF Lambda 5 white rabbits
losing to any other mobile task forces I
mean being the first ones called of
scp-953
scp-106 or scp-239 break containment and
worst of all working with Dr clef has
got to make their their tolerance for
pain through the roof however if I were
to cross-test with one I'd have to go
with MTF Epsilon 9 fire eaters something
about a team trained to handle reality
warpers versus a team whose dreams of
becoming firebenders kind of coming true
sounds epic to me on a side note in a
previous video that I also provided the
comment for which SCP mobile task force
would you join that radio neutralizing
MTF Lambda 5 Agent looked shockingly
similar to me should I be worried about
the possibility that the foundation
knows what I look like or that I may
have just made Dr clef angry resemblance
to any existing commenters is purely
coincidental and not intentional on the
part of the SCP Foundation or any
Affiliated YouTube channels did I get
that right Dr clef do you promise to
leave my family alone please put down
the chainsaw back to your original Point
seeing the white rabbits face off
against the fire eaters would certainly
make for an explosive event get it
because of Fire
moving on Chase Frost said Pandora's Box
versus samsara they would be comparable
alpha 1 and tau5 would go to samsara
every time samsara vs Abel and his
hand-picked teammates who could easily
surpass Alpha One in skill would be far
more comparable anomalous humanoid and
some of the most highly skilled human
combatants versus anomalous cyborgs how
could you turn that test down Pandora's
Box was technically disbanded following
the disastrous outcome of trying to
harness Abel's bloodlust for the
purposes of the foundation but you can
never rule out a reunion and an
unkillable warrior with an insatiable
thirst for violence up against four
cyborgs made from clones of the Flesh of
a dead god with Minds that can survive
and be recovered even if their bodies
are destroyed yeah that is the crossover
of the century and since no one involved
can truly die it is a battle that would
probably go on for a century or more too
Jason Gutman said set Epsilon 11
nine-tailed fox against new seven hammer
down and see what sort of Armageddon
would result
probably involving Heavy Artillery
tactical combat skills and a couple of
nukes no thymotology or reality warping
here just good old-fashioned combat and
a couple of nukes I'd say I like the way
that you think but it honestly just
makes me kind of nervous no launch codes
for you unknown how mysterious said I'm
going to say the most obvious one alpha
1 the red right hand versus Omega one
the Law's left hand two perfectly
opposite groups one headed by the o5
council and the other by the Ethics
Committee I seriously want to know how
this one would work out plus there is a
high chance that it has happened as
equal opposites serving special
interests that frequently butt heads it
is entirely possible these two groups
have already gone to war with each other
in the past it's hard to say since the
red right hand would probably never let
the story get out in fact someone is
looking at me through the window right
now and is making a very threatening
gesture that makes me think I should
stop talking about MTF Alpha One
immediately hmm moving on katzen said oh
MTF mu13 Ghostbusters vs MTF Omega 0 ARA
oron Omega 0 are the Saints the
foundation the memories of dead
Foundation employees and depending on
your interpretation pretty much Ghosts
working for the foundation this would be
a cross task samsara vs hammer down
would be one for the ages as well I'm
also curious how the City Slickers and
Village idiots would fare against each
other you're far from the only commenter
who proposed pitting samsara and Hammer
Down against one another in general it
seems that folks really want to see
samsara fight with other mobile task
forces and it is easy to see why since
the result would pretty much be an
scp-themed Terminator movie on steroids
but I'm more interested in the other
pairings you suggested Ghostbusters
versus what are essentially the ghosts
of the foundation itself is too
interesting to ignore meanwhile Village
idiots vs City Slickers would be the
perfect chance to see once and for all
if it takes more skill to contain
anomalies in the city or in the country
Brandon muser said Lambda 5 white
rabbits is my favorite MTF Squad because
I feel like they would have to deal with
the craziest missions the SCP Foundation
has to offer and we don't get to see
enough of them I would like to see them
be cross-tested with Omega 12 Achilles
heels because they are composed of
reality vendors should be fun and
convoluted the white rabbits specialize
in navigating unstable surreal and
controlled reality and containing
potentially dangerous persons and
artifacts capable of manipulating space
and time while the Achilles heels are a
team made up of reality bending
Personnel from an alternate universe fun
and convoluted is an understatement as a
cross-test of the two might just result
in reality itself collapsing but hey at
least it would be entertaining before
everyone turned inside out or we all
fell into an alternate Dimension filled
with a giant shrimp or whatever somebody
no seriously that's their name said I
would like to see Epsilon 9 fire eaters
and Delta 14 Winter Wonderland they have
the Opposites of jobs one is for fire
and another is for winter I'd like to
see them try to fight fire vs ice simple
elegant I like it wouldn't know what to
wear for that battle though I'm thinking
safety goggles snow pants and um
flip-flops Commander tool belt said I
would like to see alpha 1 the red right
hand meet the bright 99 oh no you don'ts
I just think it would be funny seeing a
super serious MTF meet the goofy goobers
that have to deal with over 300 Dr
brights lull after all this time the
age-old question would be put to rest
what's more dangerous physical violence
or the psychological toll it takes to
interact with 300 Dr brights all at once
I say it depends on who gets a head
start and if the doctor brights have
access to any prompts you should see
what Dr Brett can do with a rubber
chicken and a hand grenade it's not
pretty Derek McDaniel said MTF Zeta 9
mole rats vs MTF Lambda 12 Pest Control
I'm curious how would lambda-12 that has
never lost a single operator as far as I
know Fair against the mole rat team who
face so many unimaginable Horrors that
they probably have the highest death
counts out of all the task forces and
maybe the most experienced veterans in
the SCP Foundation the monotony of Pest
Control versus the unfathomable horrors
of the deep underground
honestly instead of having them fight
maybe we could just give both groups a
free counseling session instead Hannah
quintua said hmm at a 10 see no evil
which is for visual anomalies and Edo 11
Savage beasts is for auditory anomalies
let's see them work together a
collaborative cross-test rather than a
battle I like the way you think putting
those two groups together to handle a
mission as one would either be extremely
successful or result in the auditory
anomalies harming Ada 10 while the
visual anomalies went after Ada 11
knocking out both groups at once only
one way to find out whoopergamer said
MTF Lambda 14 one star reviewers versus
MTF row 9 technical support neither of
them likely have any fighting experience
so it's a fair fight now that's what I'm
talking about some viewers want to see
the most effective combatants working
for the foundation go Toe to Toe but not
you you want to throw two groups with
basically no combat EXP variants into
the ring together and see what happens
next it would be one of the most low
stakes fights in Foundation history
negative Yelp reviews and can I speak to
the manager versus hacked Instagram
accounts and those annoying emails that
say forward this to 10 friends or you'll
be cursed or you could just give
everyone a weapon take their computers
and phones and see what happens next
link said we gotta see Alpha One red
right hand vs new 7 hammer down Alpha
One is a highly sophisticated MTF unit
dedicating and risking their lives to
save the o5 council doing insanely risky
tasks that involve years worth of
training not only in fighting but
stealth 2. meanwhile News 7 doesn't give
a damn about Stealth and just goes false
to the wall the resulting conflict would
probably decimate cities and fell
National governments but it sure would
be entertaining to watch Falcon fig said
I'd honestly like to cross-test my
favorite MTF beta triple seven hekade
Spear and MTF gamma 6 deep feeders and
see them fight off d see Albert entities
considering how beta triple seven
specializes in thamaturgical combat
countermeasures and rituals it would be
very useful with gamma 6 if something
like that scenario were to happen
another collaborative cross-test hikane
spear specializes in thamaturgical
ritual analysis and countermeasures
while the Deep feeders specialize in the
investigation and tracking of deep sea
or Oceanic anomalies in order for
something to require both of their skill
sets things would have to get pretty
darn of craftian and I mean the real
deal not a super chill gamer Cthulhu
like
scp-2662 some real mind-breaking Cosmic
horror rising up from the deep broad
Ford said I would find it really
interesting to put Delta 5 Front Runners
against Sigma 66 16 tons an MTF that
specializes in infiltrating geois going
against an MTF that is made up of gois
sounds really appealing to watch
captured members from existing groups of
Interest going up against a group
dedicated to infiltrating those same
group of interests would definitely be
appealing to watch but it would probably
get a bit awkward too as more than a few
covers wind up getting blown imagine
working side by side with a guy in your
secret organization for years only to
get captured by the SCP Foundation and
find out that same guy was working for
them all along Bob was a traitor all
along even when he signed your birthday
card even when you did a duet together
at karaoke you wonder was any of it real
he promises that he really did see you
as a friend not just a co-worker and a
means to gather secret Intel for the
foundation but some ruins never heal
Dino Tales said I would have to say MTF
10 troops of literature and MTF tau5
samsara who's better to take on
narrative anomalies and author entities
than a team of cyborg demigods they
created kind of a chicken or the egg
situation there only instead of chickens
and eggs it's incredibly powerful
Supernatural cyborgs and creative
anomalies this fight would give a whole
new meaning to death of the author
that's for sure Derek McDaniel said MTF
Iota 10 damn feds versus MTF Pi 1 City
Slickers the two task forces that at
least that I know of that work in urban
environments and undercover how would
these two face each other one way or
another I can see it now the feds
driving in nondescript black cars
tailing the City Slickers down crowded
streets I'm not sure why they'd be doing
that but I really want to see a car
chase and this seems like the best
pairing to make it happen solar King YT
said ten to one that any of them would
just sit down and have a coffee when you
think about it all of these groups have
way more in common than not they all
work for the same faceless organization
they all deal with life-threatening
anomalies in their own way maybe instead
of thinking how they would fight we
should just let them kick back for once
relax and swap stories over a hot cup of
Joe just don't use scp-294 to make it
that could get that fast let them go get
a Starbucks or something now check out
SCP Elite Mobile task force explained
and which SCP mobile task course would
you join for more